the reason why we have this process is
because you can give someone who's been
accused of a crime due process he's
given an opportunity to present the
evidence and then the CPS makes the
decision the reason for that is because
everybody knows if you have a scenario
in any kind of system where the
prosecutor only provides positive
evidence to try and prosecute and he
doesn't provide the evidence that
weakens his case you will end up in
trial no matter what and then what will
happen is everybody knows even if your
innocent trial risk could go wrong and
you could go to jail hence why they have
these things in place to ensure that
doesn't happen and innocent and more
innocent people aren't incarcerated and
someone and I know you're from the
United States where there's a huge
amount of incarcerations and more than
anyone per capita around the world as
well as for example in the United States
you have much more black people Hispanic
people 300 more who have been
incarcerated so again this is an example
of another black man who's basically
being incarcerated